hello freak [ __ ] and I just said you
know hey how can I help how can I get
involved because as you know means a lot
to me I'm a native Californian and I
grew up going to Yosemite you know going
hunting going fishing using the public
lands and so it was really important to
me you know my dad was a state parks
commissioner most people don't know that
so it was this point as well this was
this was God before he was the mayor no
no no no after it's really yeah this was
after fairly recently then yeah probably
the last I would say 15 years and I know
he did it for a while and then got out
but you know he was he was big and in
the remember the toll road going through
the San Clemente no I'm not aware that
yes so they were proposing a this is an
Arnold Schwarzenegger was a was in
office and they were proposing a toll
road to go through San Clemente which
goes through trestles which is a popular
surf break and he was you know everyone
you know got behind it
Surfrider Foundation didn't want it
because it was going to destroy the wave
and it ultimately destroy the the
National Park there in second he was big
on that kind of stuff and so I've always
been you know sort of following his
footsteps hang and we got it we got to
get in front of this problem
did your dad Clint Eastwood raizy
yeah that is so crazy what is it like
having Clint Eastwood as a debt like
what's your dad do my dad is Clint
Eastwood [ __ ] he was just like oh [ __ ]
his walk away confused like what
happened to me I just got hit with a
rock I mean you look like a mad like
when I'm looking at you I see your dad
like yeah from the old Outlaw Josey
Wales days yeah yeah yeah you know
what's crazy is looking at photos of him
when he was 12 and I was 12 you cannot
tell the difference you put him in both
in black and white you can't tell the
difference
Wow yeah that's a trip yeah what was it
like growing up with him as a dad why
did you realize like holy [ __ ] I think I
realized I'm 31 so I probably realizing
I was a
eight I watched Unforgiven oh yeah
Hilo you watch that when you were eight
that's my favorite Clint Eastwood movie
about that
yeah well the high-plains drifters right
up there - why I know it's hard to lock
them down
sure sure but the Unforgiven is a dark
movie yeah it's dark
William Munny William my color of women
and children no that's a dark movie man
I'll gotta come in yeah what he said is
I was like probably one of the most
realistic killers to like the way he
handled stuff the way everybody else was
like falling apart yeah I never saw that
in those movies what was about regret it
was about a life filled of regret and
filled you know things that you did
wrong that you wish you could have you
know done better and you know sort of
one last ride to you know be to do
something better for his kids you know
so I think that was sort of interesting
he was sort of a final culmination of
all his westerns it really was and and
almost like he updated them all - yeah
because like in the old movies like
you'd have cowards you need to have
heroes and stuff like that but in the
Unforgiven he took it to a totally
different level like psychologically you
know like even the way he like the
switch goes off when he starts drinking
and he starts just [ __ ] Merck and
everybody like the way it was handled it
seemed so realistic yet the way
everybody would fall apart and gun
fights and the way they had to watch
that again now it's been a while yeah
now I'm like this sounds awesome [ __ ]
great a [ __ ] great movie I remember
seeing it I remember the movie I went to
see in the movie theater and when the
credits rolled in the end I just wanted
it Wow yeah powerful one whoo yeah it's
intense movie man [ __ ] intense so
when you're 8 you figured it out like a
living write it right around then yeah I
remember it's watching and that's what I
watch it with him or shortly after he
made it and just thinking you know that
is the coolest thing and I want to do
that you know I want to I want to be in
movies I want to tell stories like that
Wow
so how many and you have brothers and
sisters and so how did all that work
yeah I've got it I've got a few sisters
and my dad was a busy
I how many kids in the family uh what's
how many wives well yeah let's just go
that there's a he's only had two wives
please had a few few girlfriends few
different yeah so did you live with him
or idea I would bounce back and forth I
lived with my mom I live my mom but in
California until I was about seven or
eight and then I lived then we did she
moved she packed up as this kind of run
the time when they split was your mom
and actress - no no no she was just a
Malaysian flight attendant she had two
kids and my dad and we she packed up I
think when they sort of split and she
moved to Hawaii she had lived there when
she was a lot younger and so she has
always loved Hawaii and so I had gone to
Hawaii to live probably from about eight
to about sixteen Wow yeah and then I
ultimately moved back with my dad for
like the last couple years of high
school and so yeah it was it was an
interesting upbringing right I mean you
know one hand I was you know with my dad
for some time when I was in Hawaii
living there and you know if you know
anything about Hawaii as a white boy
growing up you're you're the minority
yeah yeah so it was a lot of a lot of
fish funny to show up with a haole
t-shirt on that is really my I mean
that's that's you know a lot of people
don't you know realize that you it's
pretty you know
Hawaii's very from like a warrior
society still and that's a great thing
kind of because it's still it's very
primal and it's also you know sort of
it's one of those things where there's
not a lot of tolerance for you know
someone that you don't know or part of
your family
and so you know for me it was it was it
was tough you know it was the day accept
you eventually you know sports sports
sports really bridged that gap football
I played football and that was that
really it was tough because the first
year they were like no they were like
you don't get the [ __ ] out of a suck
yeah you know I was I was a kid then I
was probably a I can't remember 10 or so
playing peewee football right right and
then as you know as I would you know you
know prove myself that I was down for
hard work and you know down to throw
hits that you know that sort of you know
bridge the gap and then ultimately they
were part of my team and then so we
would you know go to other schools and
you know play other schools and then I
was filled a Halle boy to everybody else
but they had my back now well that was
cool time to be a Buzard time and to be
a ten-year-old and also be in that
environment
sure sure that was a different it was a
yeah I didn't know any better some
writing okay well this is what I got to
deal with sounds like cars I got dealt
so they're going to man up yeah I have a
bunch of buddies who live in Hawaii and
you know they say that if you're
respectful and you're you know you're
not gonna use bag oh yeah after a while
you just fit right in and everybody's
cool it yeah I mean it it's a I grew up
also as a surfer you know this grown-ups
grown up surfing and so there's
definitely a pecking order and a respect
there that you have to learn or you're
going to learn the hard way and that's I
think that was a good thing you know
ultimately because it kind of humbles
you and it makes you it makes you know
your place hmm
which is good okay wait so I got to go
back to the fanboy stuff so I just want
to add so so there is a you started off
acting with like smaller movies fresher
then mattering Ben and tell me if I'm I
know you were in fury yeah I didn't
remember until that started to know who
you were or less fury fury was with Brad
Pitt right which was a world war two
David Ayer oh that's right yeah and then
now it feels like you now you're in the
big movies well yeah look I started 14
15 almost 15 yeah going right doing it
hysterical and people are first sort of
again a couple hit movies happening
overnight success yeah I mean about
always lucky talking about I've been at
it for 10 years you know at that point
yeah but you know I started yet doing a
tiny one line
right you know any chance I got just
just to you know get on set play any
role do any lines whatever just learn
soak it up and yeah I was doing that for
years I mean I was doing that for seven
eight years you know while I was
bartending while I was you know Valley
Park gars anything to you know pay the
bills right how important is that that
you actually worked your way through it
even though you're Clint Eastwood's son
right that's what I was interested in is
that yeah it's like it didn't feel like
he helped you and I don't know maybe he
did but no know anyone who knows my dad
would just laugh at they you know
they're they would say oh yeah I mean
you my dad's very old-school and he's
very very tough on his sons you have an
older brother and it just doesn't happen
like that in our family
there's no handouts and you want
something you got to go get it and I
can't thank him enough for that because
it never gave me any you know backup it
didn't it it didn't make me go well I
can just sort of sit around or you know
I get created drives you know I mean it
created you know hard work and driving
those are all the things that take to
make somebody successful yell give you a
22 and he made you a star of his big
movie that wasn't obably or something
that would look it would look look
really bad on him yeah look we're so and
you could I mean he could do that I
guess when in his movie but I think the
common things
well you had you know had it easy
because you know some of it he can't
just pick up a phone and call some big
director and tell him who he should cast
and if he said it would be a mess yeah I
mean it for the direct reply tell him
you know Thank You Clint but I keep not
doing that
he knows my movie and I don't know who
your son is when he went when he went on
TV and did that like thing where he had
us like a seat next to him and he talked
to mama and talked to the empty chair we
did you call him up and dad go what the
[ __ ] dad and what are you doing now I
stay out of politics I don't even I
don't I don't give two shits about
politics I guess that wasn't even
politics I was just like a play here we
got a puppet show with no puppet yeah
I did like the intent though yeah
because I hate well whatever
yeah is good with it I get it but hey
restraint of tongue and pen hey didn't
you try out or I want to know how to but
didn't you audition audition this is
Rocco this is about wheelhouse but for
American sniper I did know it does his
movie right I was just know how that go
what happened yeah I you know I
auditioned and you know I remember
actually talking about new Bradley
Cooper and I said hey you know what I'd
love to play your broad red the
screenwriters yeah and you know I was
already doing my own thing it was you
know working for a long time but I go in
periodically an audition for his films
yeah because the Clint Eastwood films
right yeah get an opportunity audition
great and I'm you know when I said that
I'd love to tell your brother Anderson
you know one of those roles and he
probably kind of looked at me like you
know I don't yeah maybe okay cool cut
brush Oliver I was friends with them and
then so you know I sort of you know said
hey you know can I get an audition to
you know go audition for this summer
dad's company and so I went and put
myself on tape it's pretty simple when
you go audition for him he's not he's
not there no one's there anything you
just go put yourself on tape with a
casting director okay and then you know
you either either hear some back or you
don't
yeah and that's sort of the that's the
end of it and a lot of times you never
do I mean that's that's how it goes for
actors yeah so that's what happened with
that you didn't put it on tape and then
didn't hear back you know you didn't say
what what definitely didn't work like
that in my family really nice eTools ago
I would never even dare to bring up
something like that fact yeah that's I
mean that's probably why you so normal
lucky yeah because look those people
that are in those sheltered families
where he's not good it's not good it's
not good for you
you
[Applause]
[Music]